hello folks and welcome to
rational science today we have an
exciting
day we're going to be talking about
parallel lines
now how much more exciting can it get
than that
but before i get to uh our parallel
lines
uh let me cover a couple issues on
extinction okay there were a couple
questions i'd like to cover that first
uh as a lot of you know i propose that
we are the last humans on earth the last
generation of humans on earth
relatively soon whatever that means to
you
um the global economy will collapse
when it does uh there will be no
incentive to produce food
or distribute food and billions will die
primarily of starvation in uh infighting
that sort of thing that's in general
terms of the
theory it's based on the fact that
animals in the past died in mass
extinctions in the same way
they died because food disappeared
for them okay so we have a question here
or a comment
it says a file says extinction 101 is
based on nothing but an assumption
extinction 101 being um
mass extinctions of the past okay
and uh first thing i got to say is tell
us
what is not what ain't okay in other
words don't tell me
uh how the animals did not die tell me
how they did
die okay you got to come up with a
theory
for how the animals in the past died and
yes
uh it's based on nothing but an
assumption all uh
theories if they're rational they have
to have an assumption
okay so that's normal in the scientific
method
you should become acquainted with it
extinction 102
that's the extinction of man that's our
specific extinction you could say it's
the extinction
of mammals also which is uh
kind of what's going on anyways you know
they talk about the sixth
mass extinction that we're already into
it
okay and uh phil says adds to it that
people are like animals
incapable of growing and raising their
own food
uh not the issue uh that food will be
extinct if money runs out
uh yeah overlooking how many people have
already switched to self-sufficiency
lifestyles
okay money will not run out
that's like saying we will run out of
inches and can't build houses
[Laughter]
okay so what's the issue the issue is uh
it's not uh whether you can grow your
own food
anyone can grow food if they're allowed
to grow food okay so the question is
whether you're allowed
to grow food what do i mean by that well
i mean that you need protection
there won't be any 9-1-1 there won't be
any army there won't be
any national guard no police
no um judges or courts to
take your grievances to um
you're on your own so the problem is
you know you might want to plant and uh
grow food other people will want to
share in your bounty
okay and so the problem is defense
okay i mentioned that the amish right
now depend
on the defense they don't have a defense
budget they depend on the defense
budget of people who uh protect them
which are which they don't even know
about which are the police and the
legal system out there once that's gone
you know
the amish have no protection and if they
have no information of what's going
outside their uh
walls right their communities
they'll be slaughtered like pigs they'll
be run over by people
desperate from the cities you know
rushing to
amish and mennonite lands and just
stealing whatever they can and killing
whoever stands in the way
so uh the problem is defense okay
defense is the number one problem for
that anyways
um here i put a little
couple comments extension 101 all mass
extinctions were the result of food
collapses
okay what you have out there from the
paleontologists so-called
paleontologists
i don't think none of them are uh
catastrophic
mechanisms that's what they propose but
not a single one can explain the only
thing an extinction theory has to
explain
which is what selectivity
you have to explain how these animals
died in this other group of animals
remained alive
and it turns out that it's a
chronological
selectivity it always is always 150
percent of the time
the old species that die that ruled
essentially the planet
and the new species that radiate with a
new vegetation
in according to my theory uh that
expands and
uh and covers the land so you gotta
explain that cell activity
you gotta explain how an asteroid for
example can discriminate
kill only the dinosaurs and leave all
the mammals alive
or in the waters you know kill the
mossasaurs or the
ammonites and the uh plankton and leave
other plankton
alive and other uh fishes and sharks
alive
turtles uh alligators you know a lot of
uh species survived and the question is
how do you do that with an asteroid
okay and the same for volcanic activity
and supernovas and all that kind of
stuff anyways extinction 102 which is
human extinction
let's go by steps here humans are
mammals hopefully some people don't
believe that that we belong to the
animal kingdom
i think they believe that we are rocks
you know minerals
maybe some people believe we are plants
uh no we
are not only animals we belong to the
group called uh
mammals okay and so we are part of a
given food chain
okay we typically don't eat uh
snakes insects i mean there are people
who do but i mean in general we don't
and most people out there you know if
they eat
some kind of uh flesh it'll be mammalian
flesh okay that's one issue uh of course
we eat chickens and
you know certainly some other type of
animals
but in general it's uh it's typically
mammals eating but mammals
and then extinction can happen if food
disappears some people don't believe
that
yeah if if god comes to earth and waves
his magic wand
okay let me put this over here it waves
his magic wand and makes all food
disappear
or maybe he uh waves his magic wand and
converts the surface of the earth
just like the surface of the moon baron
you know
uh i can guarantee right next point
there
that all humans will die if that were to
occur
okay so the the issue is by removing
food if you can remove all food on earth
you have a guaranteed mechanism
extinction
okay and uh you know i'm not sure you
can guarantee that with any other
catastrophic uh theory okay
okay i'm saying it's a food chain
collapse okay
and that is a selective mechanism if one
type of food disappears like if god only
says well i'm just gonna make the uh
plants that the mammals eat right i'm
gonna make those disappear
well only the mammals disappear and all
those other animals that eat something
else
they don't disappear so food is a
discriminary
discriminatory uh mechanism
okay food chain collapse selective
mechanism okay
and uh food disappears if money
disappears
now here we have a lot of people with
problems with there they say oh what do
you mean
food disappears if money disappears this
fall himself said uh
you know i grow my own food or a lot of
people will grow their own food
well again the question is defense there
okay uh the defense budget
you're gonna have to protect uh your
food
and i'm not sure you can do that 24
hours a day you would have to have a
group of people
who kind of patrol and uh protect
the garden and i'm not sure you can
protect acres of land
okay so there's gonna be a problem
protection protection
okay that's gonna be the main problem
but uh the question is
if money disappears does food disappear
well let's assume god comes in there
instead of making food disappear he
makes money
disappear he just waves his magic wand
and suddenly
for whatever reason right this is an
assumption
it's called an assumption okay god makes
all money disappear
no one trusts money no one believes in
money nobody
accepts money well right now the way the
world is built
or constructed or the way we're
structured
agricultural corporations produce the
majority of food on the planet and every
day they produce
more of it and distribute more of it
even you know even if they don't
produce all of it uh they almost
distribute all of it
because even the small farmers sell to
big corporations
so you could say that you know i can't
put a number to it i don't have a number
but i'll just pull a couple numbers out
of my head
i would say maybe 70 percent of the food
of the world is produced
by uh agricultural corporations
and distributed probably by 90
and 90 of it is distributed by
agricultural or
corporations related to the food
industry okay
so uh if if money were to be no more
because god comes in there with his
magic wand
okay it's an assumption he just makes
money disappear no one trusts money no
one believes in money nobody accepts
money anymore any kind of money
meaning uh no bitcoin no gold no
diamonds no
dollar bills no euros no nothing
okay you don't accept it because you
can't do anything with it
and that's what magic one does from god
okay
again an assumption once we have that
assumption in place
no one has any incentive to produce food
meaning
the agricultural corporations have no
incentive to produce food
and if they produce assuming 70 percent
and distribute 90 percent of the food on
the planet
that's it for a lot of people on the
planet and the rest can
have their little plot of land and i
hope they can defend it
that's the situation there okay in
general terms
okay and the irony is that yeah this is
just one mechanism
okay that for food for thought only
if government uh gives money if every
person on earth gives
everyone one million dollars
you eliminate food on a you eliminate
money on the planet
that's the irony of it i mean it'd be
great if instead of
like uh the united states government now
gives uh
checks uh 1400 bucks
uh to people if instead of doing that
they would give everyone one million
dollars now wouldn't you love to receive
one million dollars
if if the government were to do that
just by creating money
okay it would destroy all money
because if gives everybody one million
dollars no one has any incentive to go
to work
everybody wants to take a vacation but
were you gonna take a vacation if the
guy that
was gonna serve you you know at the
hotel and at the
restaurant and at the airline he's gone
too he wants to go on vacation too
so uh you know the whole world collapses
just by creating more money
and right now it seems like they're
doing a lot of that you know they're
creating this money and just giving it
away the question is why don't you give
me a little more
okay so that's just food for thought
okay i'm not saying that's the mechanism
uh it's part of it uh the more money you
produce the less
it is worth and all you're doing is
devaluing
the real the real value of the
proletariat in other words
uh the person who depends on a salary by
creating more money all you're doing is
devaluing
his real worth his real wages
and at some point in time you may reach
a point where you can't
uh make it to the end of the month you
can barely pay your rent
and eat and that's about it there's no
disposable income to spend on anything
else that
would uh affect a lot of industries that
depend on that disposable income
okay that's all just in general terms
okay one fellow says i think it's the
same guy uh the great depression
was the worst the economy has ever
undergone
as uh bad as it was it wasn't a collapse
uh yeah because we're talking about
something different we're talking about
a different situation today
it's no longer we're no longer in the
agricultural
uh slash manufacturing
world today we're in the service economy
and even worse
as i said a couple weeks ago um not only
are we in the service economy but the
services have changed
the nature of the services have gone
from services where you need humans
you know like uh hair cutting and uh
lawn mowing and that sort of thing you
know where you need a human to do some
work
it's a service right uh but we moved
from that to
internet services internet worker
primarily scams lots of scams out there
you know
uh girls that just want to make a buck
because they're
they look they look good you know that
sort of thing uh that's not real work uh
what can i tell you that requires a
little bit of intuition
that that's not work at all it's just
living off the fat of the land that's
all that is
and you know i can't go into more detail
with that
it's a long story but all i'm saying
with this is that
um the situation is not the same
as in the great depression remember the
great depression
one of the theories out there is that we
got out of the great depression because
of the war
the war uh created uh or stimulated
uh all these corporations to produce
machinery
arms weapons you know for for the war
effort
and you know that put people to work
uh 1941 the united states had the lowest
um unemployment ever one percent
and i guess you could include the
soldiers they were working in a way they
were receiving a pay so
in a way they you know they were doing
something and the women came out of
their houses the
housewives and they became workers they
worked in the factories
and so there was only one percent
unemployment
and that was then today we have a
totally different situation where
a lot of the work is again service
oriented and
most of it or increasingly
more of it is uh internet worker
okay so you got to keep those
qualitative notions in mind
i'm not sure you that sinks in the head
of everybody but that's
what i have in my the back of my mind
okay uh
just putting it here a little graph that
shows um
that the population declined drastically
uh in the mid 14th century during the
bubonic plague
and you know we recovered from bubonic
and people started producing children
again
and so you say well yeah there's these
up and downs sometimes you have a
disease come in there kill a whole bunch
of people
and then population continues growing
again well again that's not the
situation today
the situation today is that you know
we're not having children
and we're not having children uh because
we move to the cities so
history doesn't repeat itself okay
people say well you know in the great
depression we survived it we came out of
it yeah we came out of it because there
was a war today you cannot
have a war and pull the global economy
you out of a slump because a war won't
do it anymore
okay so war can kill people but
war will no longer put people to work
like it did in
in the 1940s that's the issue so we
don't have the same situation
and the fact that we came out of the
depression doesn't mean that we'll come
out of the next
recession depression or what i call
extinction
okay we're headed towards extinction
depres if we have a recession it's going
to turn into a depression real quick and
that depression is going to turn into
something worse okay i call it
extinction
uh and yeah it's because history does
not repeat itself you got to look at the
qualitative
factors we have a different world today
than it was in
in the 1930s and 40s
okay next issue here fella says
says uh another thing history seems to
me to be
religion at least for the most part
learning history requires
huge amounts of belief yeah
that uh that what has been written and
said
about the past is actually true no one
has seen pangaea
you know i talked about pangaea the
other day gondwana and uh laura asia
belief in it must belief in it must be a
religion people have actually seen dying
people have actually seen dinosaur
skulls which it seems that you say
are objective proof that dinosaurs
existed
but since no living dinosaurs exist
today
isn't the belief in dinosaurs a religion
isn't most of history based on belief
and therefore religion
well i define religion as belief so
every time you pronounce the word
religion
all you're saying is belief that's got
nothing to do with
pangaea or dinosaurs uh when you come to
pangea and dinosaur it's not a question
of believing anything
belief doesn't enter the picture at all
you make an assumption
you found a skeleton you found a skull
in here let me put one up there like i
put the other day
i hope this is the right one yeah here's
pangaea first
uh and uh you say well you know
this is the map and you say well was
that true i mean that happened millions
of years ago how do you know that that
was the case
and the answer is we don't do we believe
no we don't believe it's got nothing to
do with belief or knowledge
belief and knowledge both belong to
religion
what are we talking about we're saying
we make an assumption why is that
assumption more or less rational well
because the
fellow who proposes this is saying look
we found
glossopterous in this belt and that
green belt that you see on the southern
region there covering all these
continents
so the assumption is and it's a pretty
good assumption in my opinion
that you know if the glossopteries were
scattered in those regions all those
regions were
together at some point in time and
what reinforces that is the animals that
you find in south south america south
africa india australia and uh north
or or whatever antarctica uh
you know the the animals they find in
these regions
are the same animals are the same type
of animals so you have to believe
you know not believe i mean you you have
to
make an assumption that maybe all these
continents were together they had the
same floor and they had the same fauna
nothing wrong with that and the same
goes for what happened in north
you know in the north you had um these
other seed ferns and you had
similar types of animals when the north
part split in two and you had russia on
one side united states and canada on the
other
well you find similar animals on both
sides
so um in the same type of plants or
similar types of plants
it gives you an idea that these
continents were
united at some point that's it's it's a
good assumption to begin
your theory that's how it is not a
question of belief and
belief doesn't play any role whatsoever
you want to believe that's fine
it's an assumption you say let us assume
that all these animals that all these
continents work together
and the assumption is is more or less
valid because you say look
if all these plants cover this region
all these animals were in these same
regions
it's a good assumption to think that
millions of years ago
all these continents were put together
and one of the conclusions
from that is that yeah continents do
move
you know they're not static they don't
stay like that forever
and it doesn't they don't move from one
year one second to the other i mean you
won't notice that but
after millions of years you can expect
them to move and that's what
the the proponents of this say that
that's what happened that
uh continents did move and again it's
not a question to believe it's a
question of
uh is it a good assumption and even if
it's a bad assumption you can
work off of that assumption nothing
prevents you from working from that
assumption okay
and again this is what i was going to
show earlier here skulls
you find this in the rock what are you
going to think
you find that does that look like a
whale or a rhino that
one on the upper right uh does that
other one look like an elephant
so you find these in the rock what are
you gonna what are you gonna say
well you give it a name you say well
these we'll call these dinosaurs
and as well so well but dinosaurs are
not around today so
should we believe that dinosaurs roam
the earth
i don't care what you call it you want
to call it ax you want to give it a
different name
you don't like the word dinosaur fine
call it x those x's
were in the rock they they got down deep
enough
and they look at these layers and they
say well this layer
is so many took so many millions of
years to form this one so many
millions of years and so on and even if
you don't believe that
if you don't accept that assumption you
did find
a skeleton a skull in the middle of the
rock
that animal that's whoever had that
skull
is not around anymore so obviously that
animal at one point in time roamed the
earth and today not
it doesn't roam the earth anymore and
say
what animal is that well who who had
that skull
what are you going to call it x you
don't like dinosaur you want to say x
okay fine but don't tell me that that uh
skull was made by an
artist you know in in uh in his little
shop say hey i'm going to build a little
a fancy skull here and i'm going to put
it out there you know you got you have
uh people in the field working in china
in argentina and
russia and south africa and the united
states all these people find
these uh skulls and bones
skeletons you know fossils in the rock
and when you look at the animals today
none of them have any of these features
and so what are you gonna say
that these animals never were never
around so
you gotta answer these questions you
can't just say well i don't believe
not a question of belief it's a question
you gotta answer where that skull came
from
did the martians put it there okay so
that's the issue
you have to answer the questions you
can't escape the quest and say i don't
believe
belief has no no place in science
okay um i'm going to be talking about
um parallel lines but i wanted to
cover another issue which was a little
touchy the other day
that's the issue of observation does
observation play any role whatsoever in
the scientific method
is it part of is it a part of science
and a lot of people out there say
yeah of course how can you how can you
uh
explain anything if you have not
observed it
oh my god that's when i like to get my
you know my go roller here
beat him over the head you know
okay so let's let's find out if uh this
thing called
observation to observe observer
if that any of those have anything to do
at all with a scientific method
or with science okay okay um
we start with this we start by finding
out what science is
because we need to find out you know
science and scientific method
if they include observation at all
if there's a requirement for observation
and so we look up the scientific method
in the wikipedia what do we find find
this
scientific method is what an empirical
method of acquiring
knowledge and i've underlined imperial
or highlighted empirical knowledge okay
that has characterized the development
of science since at least the 17th
century
that's when the so-called scientific
revolution
took place when they said hey we're
going to do everything through empirical
we're going to collect knowledge
empirically that's essentially
the so-called scientific method of the
17th century
i call it the method of religion okay
because it has nothing to do with
science
that's what i'm going to be arguing here
okay it involves careful
observation there you have the word
observation applying rigorous
skepticism what is skepticism an issue
of belief
okay so this is what they're talking
about they're talking about
belief okay and about what is
observed skepticism of what is observed
so
one guy observes a snake and the other
guy observes the same snake
and one guy is skeptical he said i don't
think that's a snake i think it's a hose
you confused it with a snake so we have
an observation by two different people
they reach
two different conclusions and they think
that skepticism belief
or what they thought they saw
is important in this in this world in
this
scientific world keep that in mind given
that
cognitive assumptions can distort how
one interprets the observation
yeah i mean if it distorts him you're on
drugs or you've been
you know hitting the booze too much who
knows what you observed
and so the question is is observation
objective
especially when they're telling you it's
not objective
it involves formulating hypothesis okay
what is this
via induction based on such observations
again
experimental and measurement based
testing of deductions drawn from the
hypothesis
experimental and measurement you're
going to
measure and then you're going to do some
experiment i don't know what for
but that's what they're saying is part
of this so-called scientific method
okay and refinement or elimination
they're going to be eliminating
hypothesis okay
of the hypothesis based on the
experimental findings
well uh elimination means you took a
decision
means it's a belief you didn't like that
hypothesis you
just use this other one you this
different assumption this different
theory
so you eliminated who gave you the right
to eliminate
well your mind you you took a decision
it's your belief
okay you chose and uh
okay they they say it's got to do
something with experiment
observation and eliminating hypothesis
okay that's
in general terms let's synthesize all
this
okay here's the synthesis
uh so what is the so-called scientific
method
of the that came out of the scientific
revolution of the 17th century
this in a nutshell is it uh and i want
to focus on the title there
method of what research and persuasion
that's what this is it's got nothing to
do with science it's got to do with how
you do research how do you study
something
okay and persuasion how do you persuade
the peers people who think like you
to think like you that's what it's all
about and look at the
here you'll see it observe okay uh
why do you need to observe because
you're doing research
okay and i'm gonna contrast that with
something else in a little
in a minute you make a prediction they
say it's a hypothesis
if a prediction is a hypothesis then uh
the question is whether
a hypothesis is uh the same thing
as a prediction an explanation an
assumption
are those all synonyms okay keep that in
mind because they're saying it's
a prediction uh you run an experiment
why
to confirm verify the prediction
behavior description
why would you run an experiment is it to
explain something
no the explanation has nothing to do
with the experiment
the experiment is just to certify or
verify
for yourself that you got everything
under control
but you know the experiment itself you
do an experiment in front of people like
faraday used to do
experiments you know the uh club over
there you used to do experiments
live experiments so you do a live
experiment what have you learned you
know i always do an experiment here the
gravity experiment you let go with a
pencil okay so i did an experiment is
that
is that science no i have to explain the
mechanism
not the observation or the experiment i
can do a lot of experiments not
understand anything
and so the question is whether
experiment has anything to do with
science
measure you measure for what what's the
point of measuring
i'm going to explain the mechanism so i
measure the table it measures one meter
or maybe one meter and one centimeter or
whatever
is that science have i've done science
so far
you collect data for evidence what's the
purpose of evidence
you're going to be using it to convince
someone to persuade
to recruit them to your way of thinking
to
convert them is that why you collect
evidence why does what's the purpose
for a prosecutor to collect evidence
it's to convince the jury to persuade
him to think his way
to vote for his theory that's what it's
all about it's about persuasion
that's all evidence and experiments are
for experiments are for evidence
evidence is for what
for persuading uh discover a novel
behavior okay so you discovered a number
novel behavior something you haven't
noticed before
okay uh so you present evidence okay
again to persuade and convince
people vote okay this part of this
method
okay that's the persuasion part people
vote and they say
okay 50 plus one voted for your theory
for your hypothesis which is a tentative
theory in some
cases now it becomes a theory
with more evidence and at some point i
guess it becomes proof
when i guess i don't know what
percentage maybe 50 plus two
percent you know how do we determine uh
when
when a theory when the flat earth
becomes a fact
more people vote for it is is that the
way it works is that what voting is
about
by uh consensus the peers vote
um the result according to these people
is knowledge they say oh we have
knowledge now
what do you mean by that well you repeat
the process to confirm the knowledge
uh maybe you make an invention a gadget
which according to mathematical physics
proves the theory
you know uh quantum computers prove that
a particle can be at two places at once
right that's what quantum computers mean
quantum computers prove
right because if they work right they
prove
that a photon can convert into a virtual
um positron virtual electron
and then recombine again and form a
virtual photon
does quantum computers prove that is
that what
proves the theory the explanation you
just gave
and uh then obviously you can't avoid
the awarding of prizes you have to
certify
uh knowledge you gotta give an award of
some kind so that's the scientific
so-called method that these people have
okay so what is an observation well
let's go to the wiki here
it'll tell us okay says observation is
the active
acquisition of information from a
primary source
okay in living beings observation
employs the senses in science
observation can also involve the
perception and recording of data
via the use of scientific instruments
okay so you either have a conscious
being or an unconscious being
a robot the term may also refer to any
data collected during the scientific
activity so collection data collection
is also an observation
observation can be qualitative that is
only the absence
or presence of a property is noted or
quantitative
if a numerical value is attached to the
observed phenomenon
by counting or measuring okay so that's
what observation is all about
it's uh collecting data essentially uh
or at least one of the pro one of the
key
features of observation is that okay
let's see what we did this for um or
let's see if this works
here it is widen it up here a little bit
the scientific method requires
observations that's this
i think comes from the wiki of natural
phenomena to formulate and test
hypothesis what do you mean test what
are you going to test
so you test it and why is that forced to
convince yourself to
prove it to yourself to prove to your
peers
does the person on the other side of the
planet does he accept this
you know as a person who works out there
in the farms who's not aware of this
have you convinced him does he believe
in the same thing
just because you convinced yourself you
ran this experiment
you convinced yourself you observed it
you measured you took data
you convinced yourself of a description
does that person on the other side of
the planet
believe the same thing or does he
believe maybe that god did all that and
the angels and the spirits
uh interfered with your experiment
okay are you going to convince all 8
billion people
on earth it consists of the following
steps
okay ask a question about a natural
phenomenon
make observations of the phenomena okay
formulate a hypothesis that tentatively
answers the questions
uh and if you look at all that it's it's
all description and explanation in other
words
uh i mean the question is whether it's a
description
or an explanation what is the question
we're trying to answer are we just
gonna describe is that what the question
is is that what we're going to answer
we're just going to
describe or are we going to explain
something
keep that in mind this is what it's
about if we're going to just do a
description
well that's different than giving an
explanation of a mechanism
okay first one predict logical
observable uh consequences of the
hypothesis that had
not yet been have not yet been
investigated
okay so you do a prediction is that an
explanation
i mean if you predict that tomorrow at
two o'clock the
uh horse number five will win the race
and it does okay even if it does you
know
so far all we have is a description you
have no explain you haven't
given an explanation of why that horse
won or will win
and if you can tell me why you're
talking about the past
there's something that you know in
advance
you could say okay it means you have
already some kind of understanding
that the other person doesn't that's
called explanation explanation can only
do with the past
uh even though it hasn't happened you've
already visualized the movie
you either visualize watch the movie
have some experience with it
otherwise you will not be able to
predict
okay if the prediction came true it's
because you know
it's uh it's uh
it's just a description so far but if
you can explain it it's
it's something that comes out of your
experience out of your memory
okay you test the hypothesis uh
prediction by an experiment
again what is that for to convince
yourself draw a conclusion
from the data uh gather well is the
conclusion
related to description or to explanation
what do you mean
conclusion are you talking about a
description
is that what what it's all about write a
descriptive
method of observation
and the results of or conclusions
reached
uh descriptive i thought we were going
to do an explanation this is just a
description
okay have peers with experience
researching the
same phenomena evaluate the results uh
that's voting
that's just everybody raising their hand
say well i agree with you
okay so they're all from the same
religion they all decided uh the peers
you know from the flat earth all voted
for the same uh theory
or description or whatever does that
make it true
because you know all the christians
voted for
jesus christ so again the question is
whether
any of these has anything to do with um
with science
and what's the outcome of all this
well the outcome of all this i mean
after did you do all these steps
okay uh this is what we have today
we have uh all irrational explanations
here's a
listing just off the top of my head okay
warp time comes up against the skin of
earth and prevents our planet from
flying out of the solar system they're
saying that there's some
there's a wall of warp time they call it
space
time right and space time is warped that
meaning
time is warped we have a concept that
has worked
and that's what prevents the earth from
flying out you've seen the
uh uh little ball little marble rolling
around a
canvas that has a bowling ball you know
in the center okay so the little
uh bead goes around what why doesn't the
bead fly away well because there's this
wall
of this canvas up against it
and that's essentially what these people
are saying okay that there's a wall of
warped time
a created uh itself from the concept
energy big bang
um zero d zero volume infinitely dense
mathematical singularity
known as a black hole moves stars around
is that what it is
you know and again chandrasekhar proved
mathematically that's what he won his
nobel prize for
that a black hole is zero dimensional
some people don't
are not aware of that and they think
that that's not true yeah
it is true okay and i've covered that in
the past as well
dark spirits known as dark energy right
counteract cosmic pool of gravity
so here's gravity pushing everything
outwards you know i'm sorry
inwards um you have the big bang
explosion
right everything should come together
pulled by gravity but it's this
dark energy that's pushing everything
out you know from the initial explosion
i guess
um a particle can be in two places at
once
is that a rational conclusion is that
what these people came up with
after following this scientific method
so-called scientific method
okay the electron is bound by uh to the
proton by nothing
mr um rutherford he proved
right empirically to an experiment
through observation
that there's nothing between the uh
proton and the electron and yet the
electron doesn't fall to the proton nor
does it fly away spontaneously from the
atom
and so please explain why it doesn't fly
away or fall to the center
to the nucleus so we don't have an
explanation these are
these are things that we have today
electricity the flow of numbers you know
what is an electron it's a bunch of
numbers it's a
collapse of the wave function that's
what an electron is as soon as you go
and measure
the wave function collapses and what do
we have we have a number
that's what a wave function collapse is
quantum
mechanics does not propose corpuscles
it's called the particle theory and the
particle is when you look at the word
particle you get down to the nitty
gritty
particle is a concept that's a bunch of
numbers or actually one number
and so that's what electricity is uh
because it's a flow of electrons
electrons are just numbers
charges that's what they call them uh
light is a wave and what is a wave
flowing vectors
we saw that the other day uh we have all
these vectors
mathematical vectors they have uh
magnitude and direction remember some
are up some
to the side 90 degrees to each other uh
they're collectively known as the
electric and magnetic field
okay that's what it is a bunch of
vectors and that's what light is a bunch
of vectors that are flowing
does that make sense that's what they
say it is
they illustrate it so you so if you had
any doubts just look at the illustration
you'll see what it is
okay mass a bunch of particles uh
struggling upstream that's what mr um
what's his name um uh
i forget his name james
skip my mind uh you know um the particle
of the higgs
the higgs uh
flow of it's the higgs ocean really
ocean of particles
and particles flow against this ocean
that
mr higgs proposes out there okay
and okay so this is their explanation
they're saying that
mass which is a concept is the flow of
particles against this
river is against the current of the
river and some
have more resistance another and that
resistance is known as mass
does any of that make sense because
that's what that's their physical
interpretations
so these are all these are just a
listing a quick listing of irrational
conclusions
or theories that we have around today
based on this so-called scientific
method
okay so what am i getting to well i'm
saying that
here's the scientific method that these
people propose
again here it is up here and
yeah then you need observation under
that because the purpose of that is a
it's a mess of method of research and of
persuasion you're trying to convince the
jury
that's why observation is important
because
observation serves as a synonym of proof
uh here
let me show you my version okay
and this is the rational scientific
method we call it science
okay uh we only call it rational science
to distinguish it from what the
mathematicians are doing
but we it's actually science this is
science what the mathematicians are
doing is not even science it's religion
it's uh because they don't have rational
explanations there you see these are the
x
type of explanations that you get the
ones i just mentioned a minute ago
and here you can see why we don't need
the word observe or observation
where do you see the word observation on
the right hand side
well you won't see it because it's not
there because you don't need it for
anything
what is a hypothesis it's the
assumptions what are the assumptions the
object's definitions
and the initial scene or the first
frames of the movie of your of what
you're going to be explaining
so you propose assumptions remember this
is a way of explaining something to
someone
it's not a method of research and
persuasion
it's a method of explaining that's the
difference
because we're going to explain
rationally how mother nature does her
stuff out there
and what are you going to explain you're
going to explain mechanisms and causes
that's under uh you know physics
uh philosophy uh you explain uh
something else
okay we call it uh reasons
and purposes okay
and um here's the
conclusions to this so that you can see
why we don't need observation
at all in science okay and again people
ask let me put this question this person
asked the other day because this is the
question
on everybody's mind that's the one we're
going to be answering here
okay they say uh what up uh without
observation
what is there to explain well imagine
that you
go to the conference and you're going to
be explaining a mechanism
why in the world do you have to say i
observed
let me tell you what i observed now you
don't have to
say let me tell you uh i observed
gravity i felt
i observed how the pencil fell to the
floor
fell down do you need to say that
it's an irrelevant issue totally
irrelevant whether you observed it or
not
you came to the conference to explain a
mechanism
and you have to make an assumption what
are you going to make the assumption
about
about the invisible stuff about the
invisible
objects that's what they're called
they're called objects that mother
nature uses
the invisible intangible objects
that produce the phenomenon we call
gravity
that's what you're going to explain are
you going to say that you observed
gravity are you gonna say
irrelevant uh that you observed how the
pen
fell at what speed or what acceleration
what does that have anything to do with
anything
it's irrelevant totally irrelevant
whether you observed it or not
it has plays no part whatsoever in
science
in explanation explanatory science
it has in research science you know
if you call that science uh you can say
yeah i observed
these are the steps that you got to take
in order to do research
fine that's one thing it's got nothing
to do with science sciences
explaining not how you came about your
explanation you're going to go out there
and tell
the the crowd and explain
an objective you're going to give him an
objective explanation
of how mother nature does her invisible
tricks the visible stuff we've already
answered
you don't need to say i observed the
pulley
uh the rope pulling a box around the you
know tied around around around the
pulley you don't need to say any of that
you just say look there's
there's this box that goes up and how do
you go up well i pulled on the
rope that was wound around the pulley
we're done you don't have to say
observe for anything there
even if you did observe it's irrelevant
you're gonna
you gotta focus on the explanation not
not give your testimony of saying
i observed what sense does it make in an
explanation to say that you observed
okay especially things such as phenomena
such as
gravity or magnetism are you going to
say yeah i observed
that this magnet attracts that one okay
so you observe who cares who cares
tell me the mechanism of how this magnet
attracts that one for that you have to
make an assumption
about what's in between these two
magnets observation plays no
role in it because i cannot observe
what's between these two magnets
and so to say that you're going to
explain the observation that one magnet
attracts another
okay it's idiocy that's what it is using
the word observation or observe or
observer
in any of those contexts
you don't need it at all it's it's
irrelevant okay
and so here's again my conclusion on
that
so that people see where i'm coming from
on this
uh you have to distinguish the method of
research
and persuasion that these people use
versus the method of explaining
rationally
we're saying science has nothing to do
with the method of research
science is about explaining that's where
you have to burn some calories
but to say this is how i studied what
does it mean that because you studied
you
learned anything doesn't mean you're
going to pass the test because you
studied
because you you say well this is how i
spent my weekend
i observed the book i opened it up i
read everything
yeah and then you failed the test that
means you didn't learn anything
so who cares if you observed who cares
if you read
who cares if you did research if you
didn't learn anything
now the juicy part of science is coming
up with an explanation
especially for how mother nature and
father universe you know run
around the world method of research
conduces to these irrational
explanations that means the method of
research that
all these people are following does not
produce rational explanations we have
not one
rational explanation from from
mathematical physics today
there are all descriptions the
descriptions are mathematical
descriptions
is a mathematical description science
that's what you got to ask studying
doesn't mean understanding again
okay and method of persuasion is known
as religion
so if that's what you did you collected
evidence you did an experiment collected
evidence
uh and brought it to the conference does
that mean that
you did science no if you're just going
to use the evidence to persuade the jury
all you're doing is religion
that's got nothing to do with science
you're just trying to change opinions
it's irrelevant and subjective to begin
an explanation of a mechanism by saying
uh that you observed uh something
you're testifying that's all you're
doing you're introducing witnesses
okay and you need not have observed
you you need not i mean again uh stephen
hawking did he
observe a black hole ever in his life
does that mean he cannot hypothesize and
say let us assume
there's a star that collapses to a point
it's got infinite mass
and that's what's compelling other stars
to move around it in circles uh orbit
you can you can do it without having
observed anything out there you could be
blind for all you care and you
someone brings the issue to you and say
well yeah i can tell you how that's done
it's done through
mass or whatever whatever your theory is
so you didn't you did not need to
observe it yourself
you should not begin your explanation by
saying i observed
because all you're doing is testifying
you're trying to show that
that if you observed in the lab who's
going to challenge you if you saw it
with your own eyes and all these other
people who were with you
we saw the photon go by oh yeah
and you saw the photon turned into two
virtual particles which recombined into
a virtual photon you saw that
you saw entanglement you saw how this
particle here
sent magical spirits and affected that
particle over there you
you observed that right or did you just
observe two particles
okay and again observe means watch you
can only observe something over time
this is not c or look look means that
you just got c means that you
gawked and understood but you can see a
wall and you can see
you know a painting you can see a still
image
observe is something else observe is not
see the amount of sin in mmc
observe is a synonym of watch
it involves time it involves motion it
involves many frames of the film
okay so and then a lot of people think
that
explanations have something to do with
technology and they say well if you
cannot produce a gadget
uh some technology then what is your
theory worth
the theory has nothing at all to do with
technology
one of the things that uh fell like
tesla nikola tesla
he never understood he thought he was a
scientist he was a guy who did
inventions he had no idea what science
was he explained everything with spirits
okay he used uh words such as energy
field
mass uh less mass because he was not on
the mass side
but he used words like field and energy
and charge
you know concepts that's what he moved
around and towards the end of his life
he
put the icing on the cake he said
someday someday
we'll discover what electricity is
meaning that towards the end of his life
he had no clue what electricity is
and there is no one on planet earth in
mathematical physics
who has any idea what what electricity
is they cannot explain it
they cannot explain the mechanism they
say it's a flow of electron beads but
for that you have to have the right atom
you can ask if you cannot uh illustrate
your atom to begin with you have no
theory
you cannot even begin to theorize okay
okay so that's it for observation let's
get to the
subject matter of today which is
parallel lines and it's more or less
related to what i just discussed
so what are parallel lines well for this
we have to go
all the way to the days of the greeks
okay
and we find mr euclid who more or less
synthesized
uh what the greeks believed and what the
romans later on passed on to us to the
western world
about what uh geometric figures were
specifically for the subject matter
today the
parallel lines okay what is a parallel
line or
uh parallel line what are they
and you find in definition 23 book one
he says parallel straight lines are
straight lines
which being in the same plane and being
produced indefinitely
in both directions do not meet one
another in either
direction uh-huh but uh
so is he how can a line grow i mean if
he's gonna
extend the line where does the line
begin where does a line end
what is he talking about well again we
had that problem the other day where you
know all these little
dots that you see there those make up
the line a line is made of points
and it turns out the points are zero
dimensional according to
mr euclid they have no what he said
which has no part meaning it has no
dimensions
okay and so if it has no dimensions he's
just described nothing
so what is he talking about well he's
talking about locations
let's say it bluntly that's what he's
talking about and if a line is made of
locations of all these points of all
these
uh you know he calls them points these
dots but they're not dots the dot
represents a location and what we're
talking about is an itinerary
he's talking about uh you know a series
of locations that's what we call an
itinerary a trajectory
perhaps an orbit if it's uh circular you
know
okay so that's uh mr euclid's version uh
hopefully we improved on it after all
these years right but i want to just
make a comment here
someone uh who
you know made a comment in the uh in the
primary
uh uh analysis of euclid
it's by clark university you can look it
up
and he says euclid develops the theory
the theory of parallel lines in
propositions
uh there was another i think it's
i-27 through i-31 anyways i covered
those
and if you look at those none of those
are
theories now this is a guy from today
this is a guy who's alive today he works
at
he's a professor at clark university he
wrote this he says
the theory of parallel lines these are
not theories these are descriptions
definitions maybe tactologies none of
these
are theories so that's let's start there
these people don't have any idea what a
theory is a theory
is an explanation the word theory and
explanation
are synonyms perfect
synonyms there is no other definition of
the word theory valid in science
okay so um a theory is an explanation
explanation is a theory
and none of these propositions that
euclid had
are theories okay so you can look them
up read them
you'll find out they're all either
description definitions or tautologies
none of them are theories so i don't
know why he introduced the word theory
it just shows
his ignorance and this is a professor at
clark university
okay what's the modern version of our
parallel lines hopefully we improved on
euclid i mean after three thousand years
you would think that hey we're beyond uh
euclid
okay let's find out and this is the
definition we have today out there
it says parallel lines are lines in a
plane
which do not meet that is two straight
lines in a plane
that do not intersect at any point are
said to be parallel
that's in wikipedia and you'll find it
everywhere it's not only in the
wikipedia okay
okay there i do two lines it's in a
plane the plane is a specific plane
that's called a square
okay in science and we have the square
we have
two lines uh drawn there
on on this plane and they do not
intersect
so uh are they parallel do you think
those two lines are parallel to each
other
because it meets the definition says
lines that are in the plane which do
not meet these two lines do not meet do
not even touch each other
so that definition has a problem
okay because it says two lines there we
have two lines
and they don't meet they say ah bill but
you cheated see those are not lines
what do you mean they're not lines now
those are line segments
line is something else oh
okay so what is a line
okay uh first let's find out what a line
segment is so we can contrast it here's
uh the notion of a line
segment okay nice segment is a part of a
line that is bounded by two distinct
end points okay there you see the two
end points are red
colored them red so that you can know
what an endpoint is
and contains every point on the line
that is between its end points okay so
that's
the so-called line segment what they're
trying to tell you is that this
line segment has a beginning and an end
okay and it is finite okay a closed line
segment includes both end points uh an
open line summary includes
excludes both end points and a half open
line segment
uh includes exactly one of the endpoints
okay fine these are categories okay so
they're saying that the two
on the left that i drew there uh
they're not lines they're line segments
and they're talking about lines
okay my error my mistake
okay um so uh here we see
that if we follow their definition of
line
you have to extend these lines and once
you extend them okay they do
cross but you know they're outside in
this case they're outside the
square which is a plane and what they're
saying is the plane is
infinite whatever that means i never saw
an infinite figure
so you know they're just saying it's a
it's a continuous surface
so to speak so extends forever and so
you can extend the lines forever as well
they're not talking about a specific
plane like a circle or a triangle or a
plant
or a square because if you did that you
would have to remain within the
boundaries
of that square of that circle and so on
and maybe the lines don't intersect
but again they're saying uh those aren't
lines those are line segments
and the plane is infinite in other words
it's not a figure
they're not playing they're saying it's
just a
continuous surface that extends forever
that's what they're saying
okay so we let's work with those
definitions
but for this we have to go back and find
out uh you know what a line is
and we look up the definition of the
word line
and we're horrified okay why because we
find out
that it's a primitive concept oh
primitive concept okay let's see what it
is uh
all definition this i think is out of
the uh wikipedia also but
all these places have the same notions
all definitions are ultimately
circular in nature so they start already
with a warning
don't expect the definition of the word
line because all definitions are
circular
okay since they depend on concepts which
must themselves have definitions
a dependence which cannot be continued
indefinitely without returning to the
starting point
uh yeah it looks like these primitives
are going around in circles you know
okay to avoid this vicious circle
certain concepts must
be taken as primitive concepts terms
which are given
no definition sounds like you're
alluding
the definition because you can't define
because
as long as you define in terms of other
words
that do not need specific definitions
as long as you can distinguish then you
have a valid definition
to say that you can't define any term in
the dictionary
especially those that we use in science
you know that the one
that make or break your your case your
theory
uh that's just alluding the the question
you have to make clear to
the audience what you're referring to
when you
you know when you're going to use the
word line and if it's a geometric figure
you're not going to define it because
you don't define figures you point to
them
and of course you can't point to a
one-dimensional line especially if it's
an itinerary
a bunch of locations which is not a
geometric figure
and so so and so on so that's why it's
so circular and these
poor primitive uh mathematicians are
just going around in circles
in geometry it is frequently the case
that the concept of line
is taken as a what primitive
okay so these people are alluding to
question that's all they're doing
and just in case you know they have um
also the back and forth line okay this
is the back and forth line
uh the concept of a primitive notion may
be too abstract to be dealt with in this
circumstance
it is possible to provide a description
or mental
image of a primitive notion yeah because
all you have to do is point to it that's
why you have a mental image
you don't that's how you present a
figure in science
especially in physics these are not true
definitions
and could not be used in formal proofs
of statements
the definition of line in euclid's
elements
falls into this category there is no
generally accepted agreement among
authors as to what an informal
description of a line should be
when the subject is not being treated
formally
okay so yeah these people are all
they're doing is going around in circles
and back and forth you know
uh eluding the question and the question
is what the hell is a line
and they say well we can't define it
well not only you can't define it you
can't point to it because it's
one-dimensional
you can't draw it because whatever you
draw is two-dimensional
and then you extend it forever because
you're talking about an itinerary a
bunch of
locations so what the hell are you
referring to
what is this famous line of yours and if
you don't know what a line is
much less can you know what two parallel
lines
are or maybe we can let's find out maybe
we can
so uh here we have uh what is the line
well it's a bunch of points remember
and what is the point point is a
primitive notion also
we have all these uh cavemen all these
neanderthals you know and they
it's all primitive uh that models an
exact location
so it's a point it's a location in space
they say
it has no length with our thickness okay
so what are we talking about
we're talking about location and a line
is a set of all points in fact uh you'll
find another statement there says
when n equal one the set of all such
locations
and that's what they're talking about is
called a one-dimensional space
okay so what are they talking about how
they're saying that a line is a bunch of
locations
an example of a one-dimensional space is
the number what
line so they're talking about numbers
what are those numbers they're
locations they designate or stand in
lieu
of locations so we're talking about
locations locations location
you know if you want to sell your house
you know just use that term okay
okay so what is a line well here it is
okay here's illustrated
i this illustrated this the other day
it's a bunch of locations
it's uh the locations the turtle had in
each
frame of the film of the universal movie
that's what it is just a bunch of
locations it's an itinerary
it's the itinerary of the turtle that's
what a line is they're not talking about
a geometric figure they're talking about
trajectories okay and so uh
what does this take us to well here
here's what two parallel lines are okay
this is
essentially you know what it is is a um
what
what they've defined is a way to come up
with
parallel lines okay they're saying if
you want to know if these two lines are
parallel
hey all you have to do is go to infinity
okay how to find out whether two lines
are parallel that's what they're trying
to
uh tell you or describe or whatever it's
it's a
it's a spec a specification of how to
tell
whether two lines are parallel or not
they say line is a series of locations
that's what it is
you add all these locations until you
get tired and beyond you know you just
can continue
putting dots locations one right after
another all the way to infinity and
hopefully you come back someday okay and
uh
ensure a location of one itinerary
does not cross the path of the other
until you
verify that you can't come back so you
have to follow these lines all the way
to infinity
right wherever infinity is and only
if they cross can you come back and say
um they did cross
so they're not parallel and meanwhile
you have to continue rolling because
you know that line continues growing on
you it's a bunch of location a bunch of
itinerary
you got to continue going straight
known as rectilinear rectilinear
trajectory
so you have to go on and on and on and
find out if anywhere do they cross
until they do you can't come back okay
so here's uh what we call
parallel lines very simple it's a very
objective you just stare in
in one second without any wording you
essentially understand
what parallel lines are okay here it is
okay these are parallel lines they're
known as parallel lines what's the
what's the criteria equidistance okay
there's
they maintain the same distance
throughout and are they
eternal lines a bunch of locations uh
itineraries no what they are is what
these people call line segments
it's not even that because the line
segments are also made of points which
are locations
these are not a bunch of locations it's
a stick that's what it is a continuous
stick made of a single piece
and they just maintain the same distance
from where you see it begin to where you
see it end
that's it and those are known as
parallel lines
see how easy it was all these years all
you got to do is point and say that's a
parallel line why because they're
equidistant
and we're done even a child understands
that
you don't need to extend the line and
say it's a bunch of points it's an
itinerary it's an orbit
we don't need any of that okay
understanding
um parallel lines is one of the simplest
concepts
in science i don't know about geometry
but it is in science
okay with that let me get into some of
the
questions and comments people made okay
here's
the first comment
uh fellow says says you called the
actual true one
in capital letters okay a liar and
religion
this world is going to continue to grow
more and more vain and delusional
because they have rejected and despised
god
what i have trouble believing is two
things first that there are people today
that still
are proposing god as a solution to
everything you know god made the flowers
the bees
the world that's one issue the other
issue
why do these people even
you know browse
scientific sites sites of physics
are they going to bring god and say yeah
we do everything by magic
god brings his magic wand he does
everything by magic we don't have to
understand it we just have to believe in
god
my god oh my god
okay another fellow he raises another
issue
he says uh to believe means
not to know okay
and since no equals justified true
belief all you said
is that belief means not to believe
that's all you said and so here are some
pointers for you
you cannot use negatives to define words
scientifically you cannot say
a horse is not a dog
and not a cat not a tree not a rock yeah
i know
what we're gonna use the not every word
in the dictionary
is that what a horse is okay so you
can't say
intelligence is is not data
and it's not charge it's not mass it's
not
what is this a guessing game so you
can't use
not uh negatives to define
and part of that is because a negative
definition is
known as an antonym it's the opposite
and antonyms and synonyms are both
outlawed
because both are circular uh so-called
definitions there's no definition
whatsoever okay that's that's what it is
so no you can't use the not
sorry uh you got to learn to define
words
scientifically in order to define
scientifically you need to use
words that are neither antonyms nor
synonyms
okay and here's another one and that's
why all these people
just said a minute ago that uh
everything is primitive or because you
can't define
any word because all words require other
words and all words
then require other words to be defined
and so it's
eternal and so we might as well not
define anything we can't define any word
no in science we can define it's in
religion where you can't define because
you're trying to protect your religion
okay so yeah you can't use synonyms or
antonyms a fellow says you cannot change
the meaning of the words that all
humanity has been using for millennia
so this fellow says if there's a
definition which is
irrational we should continue using it
because of tradition
and because you're not going to change
the minds of all people on the planet
well i don't care i don't care if every
person on the planet is against me and
votes against me
i'm gonna make my presentation i'm gonna
make my dissertation
i'm gonna explain my theory for that i
need to define
terms okay he who doesn't agree with my
term doesn't like my terms
no problem come up to the ring and
defend
your definition destroy my definition
defend yours
if you cannot do that get out of the
ring and
think about it some more and right now
you have to accept my definition
because you were not able to destroy my
definition
and second you had nothing to present in
the alternative
see how simple it is so we don't care
how many people on the planet vote for a
definition
if it's irrational it should be rejected
we have to redefine the term
especially for scientific purposes
because we're going to give scientific
interpretations physical interpretations
and we need to understand the
terminology
okay you can't escape that so you can't
use tradition and voting
as criteria for why we should keep using
irrational definitions if you don't
understand that way i can't help you
you can continue believing whatever you
want using the definitions of the
dictionary which are
all unscientific all of them i haven't
found a single definition that is worth
anything out of the dictionary i had to
change them all
because you can't use them in science
that's why you can't use them
consistently which is the criterion
that you should apply paul says science
is knowledge
how can you say the word knowledge is
not defined
well uh knowledge is defined as
justified true belief so
knowledge is just belief knowledge
another definition acquaintance with
facts
truths or principles as from study or
investigation
okay what is the truth what's a verified
or
indisputable fact
indisputable you mean uh
there are people everybody on the planet
believes in god
proposes god everybody in the plant
believes in the flat earth
we know that the flat earth uh that's
how the
earth is it's flat we all know this it's
now it's common knowledge
and by encountering i mean all persons
on the planet believe
and know this for sure everybody
knows that there are black holes
everybody knows that big bang happened
everybody knows there are uh alternative
realities
that a particle can be in two places at
once we all know
this eight billion people on the planet
so what is knowledge does it mean
consensus doesn't mean we raise our
hands and vote
fifty percent plus one what's a
criterium for knowledge
and so uh it says facts truth or
principle okay what's the truth
a verified or indisputable fact what's a
fact fact
something known to exist or to have
happened
known so they go back to knowledge
so uh uh knowledge is belief it's also a
fact truth what is truth it's also a
fact what is fact
it's something known we go back to known
so we have we have a circular definition
and that's why these people say well
these terms are primitive we can't
define them we have no possibility of
defining these terms
yeah because these people are chasing
their tails around they're going around
in circles
they're not scientists what they are is
people who go to the dictionary
and just borrow the definition they
found there may be put in there by a
librarian who has no
stake in physics just pulled it out of
the
older dictionaries all people who again
had no stake in physics and we're just
going to do it because of tradition
because that's what it means in the
ordinary speech in our common language
now in science we have to define terms
uh precisely because we need to convey
thoughts
precisely you know uh accurately
and uh gives an example space travel is
now a fact
yeah tell that to the flat earthers they
don't believe that we went to space
a lot of people even though there are
not even flat earthers
they don't believe that we went to the
moon or that we sent uh probes to mars
or that man can go beyond
you know the protection of the
uh that we have you know magnetic field
and so on out there
they believe that if you go out into
space you die and uh so they don't
believe man has gone into space but says
space travel is now a fact for whom
no in science we do not say fact we do
not say
truth okay because the next one says a
truth
known by actual experience or
observation
and so uh well which one is that like uh
the existence of god okay is that a
truth known by observation by experience
maybe by experiment
yeah anytime people use the words
knowledge truth
fact they're talking about religion
anytime you introduce experiments and
evidence
you're talking about religion you're
trying to persuade
that's the only purpose of experiments
and evidence
experiments uh collect data to
create evidence for what to persuade the
jury
that's why we don't use experiments or
evidence in science that's religion
and we don't use these words such as
knowledge
which is belief truth or fact because
they
belong strictly to religion fact means
you already made up your mind
unfortunately the way you made up your
mind is not the way the other guy across
the street made up his mind he made up
his mind in a different way than you did
so it is a fact to you is a lie to him
and until you understand that you will
not will continue to be uh
to use words such as fact truth and
evidence and uh
knowledge and so on you got to come out
of
that language that language is no good
in science uh serves no purpose
okay another comment question here
fellow says hypothesis
is defined as justified belief aha
that is not known to be true
true meaning opinion what is true to you
is a lie to your neighbor
you know you think it's true that he
slept with your wife
and he says it's not true and your wife
says the same thing now someone is lying
or someone is ignorant but you can't all
be
true uh you cannot be right you cannot
all be
correct someone's wrong okay so whatever
true means i don't know and if it's
belief justified belief to whom to you
to you it's a justified belief to your
neighbor it's not so who's right
again all that's subjective thus a
hypothesis
is a belief yeah uh
if if that's what hypothesis means to
you how about this something else in
science but in religion yeah it's belief
that is backed up with some supporting
evidence evidence to convince
whom the pope
uh does he present evidence of god or
brings the bible and says this is what
the bible says that's proof that's
evidence
okay but it may still be false
so if it's false then how can it be true
again these people live with these
contradictions that the contradiction is
in the statement she's talking about
truth and it says it could be false
so if it could be false maybe it's not
true again
opinion belief you know what is this
religion a hypothesis proposes a
tentative
explanation or prediction is an
explanation the same thing as a
prediction
i predict that tomorrow uh there will be
an eclipse at three o'clock
is that the same thing as an explanation
um
uh yeah there was an eclipse uh 500
years ago for this reason this is the
cause the
how it happened you know uh the moon got
in between the sun and the earth
that's how it happened so is that
explanation the same thing as saying
uh tomorrow two o'clock or three o'clock
there's going to be
an eclipse so far you haven't explained
anything all you did was make a
prediction
and again you know if there's an
asteroid and destroys the moon there
won't be an eclipse
and you did not know your prediction did
not come true
hopefully it destroys the moon and not
us you know the earth
a theory on your hand on the other hand
is a substantiated
explanation for an occurrence
is that what a theory is an explanation
or a substantiated
explanation substantiated means that you
you're going to believe it that it they
convinced you of it
that's what substantiated me explanation
is just objective
i can explain a mechanism even though
it's not substantiated by
absolutely anything why do you need it
substantiated
to have proof to have evidence so that
you're convinced is that what
substantiated means
no explanations are all objective in
science
you explain a mechanism you say look i
can explain
how this magnet attracts that one and
you give an explanation for that
mechanism we're done that's the
objective explanation did you understand
okay once you understood we're done
now substantiation you know that's
something else you're saying let me tell
you why
let me tell you why i believe this let
me give you proof evidence this is the
experiment that i've done and that's
what i came out with
well that's uh that's evidence that's
substantiation that's
belief so no it's not a substantiated
explanation it's just an objective
explanation theories rely on tested and
verified data no they don't
i don't need to verify anything i don't
need to
test anything i give you a theory of a
mechanism
i say this is how a car works okay
did i verify anything maybe maybe not i
don't have to verify anything
now i can tell you how gravity works
without verifying anything without
running any experiment i just tell you
look this is the mechanism the objective
mechanism of how the earth goes around
the sun or the moon around the earth
and i give you an objective mechanism so
that you understand not so that you
believe it
okay and uh but he continues as in
scientists why the accepted theories
i don't care if scientists if they
accept that they're not scientists
they're religious monks
okay accept it means that they're gonna
talk about belief opinion that's what
accepted means
so in science we don't accept theories
in science we
explain theories we give an explanation
of a mechanism
objectively and that's it whether it's
widely accepted that's religion
that's that's because people form the
club there and
you have all these clubs you have the
flat earthers you have the flat
universers
they're known as relativists they
believe in the flat universe
okay uh to be true true by whom
uh opinion though not unimpeachable i
like that it
says they're true but that doesn't mean
it's uh unimpeachable you you can still
channel they could be false
so are they true or false i mean if it's
true it's true forever
it can't be true today the flat earth
can't be true today and then tomorrow we
discover this not true any longer
you can't have that back and forth say
it's true today
but we were wrong then it wasn't true
don't talk about truth if it's
your opinion today that's why science
only deals with objective
mechanisms that you can explain you know
again objectively so that people
understand it now so they believe it
whether it's true or not that's religion
evidence evidence is when the theory
explanation has
met observations and experiment okay
so we had all these series a minute ago
where uh
you know see if i can get it up there
again here it is
there are these uh theories that these
people came up with okay
let's put it over here i know i got the
wrong one
uh give me a second here
here we go
okay how about these series are they uh
all from observation and experiment warp
time
matter created from nothing zero deep
volume uh
pulls on a star uh zero
the volume and infinite density right
dark spirits
particle two places at once uh particle
is the collapse of a wave function
a wave equation huh is that are these uh
theories uh based on observation and
experiments
i mean these are the theories of
mathematical physics
a religion of mathematical physics so uh
uh has observation served us any purpose
has
the fact that we run experiments served
us any purpose
if these are the conclusions of the
people who
run the world of so-called science
meaning
mathematical physics i mean these are
the explanations they give
you would think that the so-called
scientific method that we're
using since for the last 400 years since
the 17th century
uh could be mistaken
at best yeah it means that we don't have
really a uh a good scientific method out
there that these people are using and
which people are passing from one
generation to the next
okay and there you have them yeah sorry
i'll put it up there again
okay uh next issue
i just wanted to talking about
observations just wanted to mention this
let me make this a little bigger okay
observation
uh like you know
we cannot observe uh why we cannot touch
for example right
or see light all we can do
is see how things move like you know one
atom approaching another
meaning one atom that belongs to the
table moves to
closer to one uh atom belongs to a chair
for example
okay so they move together they move
closer to each other
but the question is you know what is in
between them
is there something there simply because
we can't see or touch it that means
there's nothing there
is that what we're going to conclude and
so i just wanted to show
that you know why observation really is
not
a very a very good way of telling uh
something about mother nature's universe
here you have a hand
okay and what i did is i put in there uh
one atom in each finger okay so assume
the
hand is moving perfectly rectilinearly
moving
through through the air okay and
why can't we touch those robes well we
can't touch or see them for that matter
because the atom
is sliding along the ropes that are
connected to the atoms of the ball
okay so the atoms are sliding and that's
why we can't touch
that rope that interconnects the atom
from
uh the ball to the atoms that make up
the hand okay
and you can see it just slides through
there why because as you see here
an atom just slides and reels in you can
see it reeling in
the rope that goes right past it goes
over and
through the center okay the in other
words one thread goes around the other
one
goes through the center and that's why
the atom cannot touch the rope
okay and once again here it is uh you're
you see your
hand the atoms they're just sliding
along the ropes that's why you can't
touch the rope
and you say well how about the crops
that cross
and first you need to understand this
and the other one uh
i also will go through it but i mean if
you cannot
understand this we might as well not
even move to the other one okay
here i'm showing you that if your hand
slides
along the ropes you can't touch the rope
that's coming perpendicular
to that atom because the rope uh
forks out at the electron shell one goes
over the other one goes through the
center and all you're doing is sliding
through the rope so you can't touch the
rope
itself all you can touch is another atom
once you come in contact with it right
and that's a long story also what the
word touch means but
what i'm saying is you know you're
sliding along the rope that's why you
can't touch the
the rope you can't touch gravity because
the gravity is mediated by these same
ropes
you're just sliding your hand through
the ropes
they're going past you you're just going
that's why you can't touch these ropes
okay and that's why observation is not a
good criterion because we cannot observe
let alone touch the mediator of gravity
of light
of magnetism we cannot touch those or
see them
okay and when follow says
uh uh he says that at the center this
fellow believes that gravity is
magnetism
for people at the center of the planet
is a
zero gravity environment at the center
of a magnet is a zero magnetic
magnetism environment this is similar
this is a similar configuration
both to attraction i showed the other
day
that gravitational field of the earth by
no means matches the configuration right
of the magnetic field of the earth
they're they're two different i mean if
we sprinkled iron filings
uh around the earth if if we just
include the magnetic field it would have
that pattern and if we just
include the gravitational field it would
have a different pattern one would be
circular and the other one would have
that
double uh with that wing shape okay
so no the magnetic field by no means
matches the gravitational field
configuration okay uh
you know if you take um uh
say the moon right uh when the
astronauts fall on the moon
right stand on the moon for those who
believe that astronauts went to the moon
we can have gazillions of astronauts
standing on the moon which has very
little to no
magnetism okay and if you could take a
picture
like you're from you know a bird's-eye
point of view from god's point of view
you would take a picture you would see
that all these astronauts would be
pointing outwards
all around the moon you would have
gazillions of astronauts
they would all be pointing perpendicular
to
to the you know to a plane uh going
through the center
of the moon okay so that would be
like you see the gravitational field
there that's not what you would see if
you sprinkled
iron filings uh say around
a planet such as uh jupiter
okay it would have that shape that
double wing
shape so no magnetism has nothing at all
to do with gravity there are two
different mechanisms
and yeah uh the tesla folks the
the electric universers all these people
they believe
that electricity and magnetism have
something to do with
with gravity and you know one of the
things i always
uh like to show and here i showed it the
other day here i'll show another version
of this okay
and that's um this that
every iron filing is attracted one by
one
a magnetic field is something sweeping
something that's sweeping inside a
magnetic field something that is in
motion
and there you see it the first magnet is
under water the second one i showed the
other day
you throw you you hit a bunch of iron
filings that are sitting on a canvas
okay
and there's a magnet there and you can
see how the magnet in slow motion
attracts
one iron filing at a time
okay so in both cases the iron filings
that are attracted
one at a time here's a million dollar
question
don't tell me what a field is don't talk
about the word field just tell me what
physical
object draw it really uh if possible
show me
what physical object came in contact
with one iron filing
okay so if you think it's gravity if you
think it's uh magnetism i don't care
uh tell me draw illustrate the physical
object that came in contact with one
iron filing with one i'm fine we'll
eliminate all the others i want to know
what physical object
force that iron filing to come closer to
the magnet
that's what you need to show okay and if
you cannot do that
don't tell me that gravity is magnetism
or electricity or anything like that
because you still
have not been able to illustrate what
physical object came in contact with the
iron filing
and hopefully something came in contact
with the iron filing
otherwise you're doing it with black
magic you're saying that the magnet
somehow
affected this iron filing with nothing
in between
or outside what are you doing
uh physics with uh angels
black magic god you gotta explain what
physical object came in contact with
with each one of those iron filings
otherwise you have no theory
to say that gravity that gravity is a
concept to say that magnetism that's a
concept too
we don't use concept we don't move
concepts around we don't move fields
uh around what we move is objects you
gotta identify the invisible intangible
object that came in contact with the arm
filing with one
fire filing until then you have no case
okay that's that's the what a physicist
does
religious people do something else some
things actually can be
objectively proven with evidence aha
proof and evidence seem to be synonymous
but prove
uh proof i guess and evidence do not
seem to be
synonyms to me oh okay
you use evidence and proof to prove
something is true
oh my god true to whom to you to the
pope to whom who's gonna believe you
okay and uh so here's the continuation
of that
fellow says the following he says
let me get this down uh someone throws a
rock through a window
and i record it on camera i can now show
you this video
as evidence to objectively prove how the
window was broken
i can also objectively prove that a rock
has the ability to break a window by
throwing a rock through one
i don't think anyone in the world except
bill gates right
could watch me throw a rock through a
window and still say they don't believe
a rock can break a window
i feel like everyone can universally
agree that this is
valid evidence that objectively proves a
rock can break a window video footage
could be used to objectively prove
many things
okay is this uh true should you believe
them
so uh let's let's put a case i mean we
had tons of these cases
um especially in forensic files
where they tried to trick the detectives
okay
and so let's let's play devil's advocate
here okay
uh we poison the woman okay and she dies
and then as soon as she dies you put a
knife through her back
and you film it okay so the film shows a
knife going through the back
case closed the woman died of a stab
wound right well the autopsy says
something else because obviously you
were trying to mislead
the detectives and so on with anything
especially with videos
today you have videos showing man going
out into outer space
the flat earthers don't believe it even
though they're staring at that they say
no that was all done in hollywood
that's how much people believe in your
video
so maybe you have a reason to show how
the window broke and so you say well
look
i'm gonna throw a stone okay and i'm
gonna break the window
bill did you see it yeah i saw you throw
the stone i saw you filming
i believe that you broke the window by
throwing a stone
through it me that's just me because i
saw it
now prove it to the china man on the
other side of the planet
you say look this is what i showed bill
i threw the stone and i filmed it how i
broke the window the chinese man said
well i think you're just
a little too eager to prove your theory
on me i don't believe that it was a
stone that broke it i think the window
broke by itself before the stone got to
there in fact i don't even think it was
a stone i think it was a turtle
or maybe you just painted
you know uh the uh you know photoshopped
the stone into your video
so no you're the only one who believes
videos okay on the planet
you should not be so gullible okay no we
do not believe
videos okay you have to make sense
of how something broke and if the sense
is that a stone broke it so be it
you believe that when someone else
believes something else you just explain
the mechanism
in science just say look i think this is
a way it broke
i think uh stone went through the window
fine the other guy says no i think it
was a crowbar
and the other guy says something else
yeah but i filmed it yeah that's
i don't believe in your phone period
see only the people who were there
believe that the e.t came and
talked to them and you know came down
with his flying saucer
everybody else who didn't see that they
don't believe but i filmed it
here's the film i filmed it when the guy
came down all green you know
antennas we don't believe you we don't
believe the film
sorry films don't prove anything
especially in science okay final issue
here it is
uh oh we have a flat earth there yeah
the earth is not a globe bill all this
supposed rational thinking and you still
believe standing bodies of water
are rotund uh yeah
i'm so gullible i believe in this
nonsense sorry you know
i base objective inquiry on what can be
practically demonstrated
another experimentalist empiricist they
want to prove
through experiment and they end up with
a flat earth
okay keep that in mind practical reality
without conceptual
gibberish shows time and time again that
the surface of a standing body of water
is a horizontal level plane all these
people
think that there's no way the oceans
could
curve around the earth
if the earth were you know if it were a
sphere
they say every time i pour water in the
dish it's always
flat uh yeah two three centimeters
maybe a foot yeah it's always level
right and you can put a level in there
so you see it's level it's always flat
there's no way you can tell me that that
water's gonna curve unless
you know the uh the dish is curved or
something right
but uh but they always use this uh
water thing and again in this uh
individual flat earther he should try to
wake up i've
said this a million times already i'm
going to say 1 million or one i hope it
doesn't
offend or bore anyone out there okay
here's water curving around
the earth why water curves around the
earth why
oceans uh curve
uh together with the earth because the
curve where uh the earth
is a globe it's a um a sphere of some
kind close to the sphere it's not a
perfect sphere but
and here it is okay pay attention please
okay you'll find out why
water curves okay water curves it's not
flat
water curves here it is okay watch it
closely you have an atom that forms part
of the water
what is that atom pulled towards well
it's tied with
every every atom in the universe is
interconnected by
electromagnetic ropes those are those uh
lines that you see there
and so you see all those lines are
pointing towards the center of the earth
for that atom for this atom
every rope pulls it towards the center
of the earth and that atom is also
pulled towards the center of the earth
so every atom around the earth is pulled
towards the center of the earth
that's why gravity works towards the
center of the earth
and it works for any celestial object
that's why almost all celestial objects
stars galaxies
well not galaxy but stars it's
individual
items such as stars and um
moons and planets that's why they're all
spherical
they're spherical because all the atoms
are pulled towards the center
now if you don't understand that there's
a physical mechanism
you know that is showing you how gravity
works
gravity works because every atom of
water
even on the surface and even below is is
uh connected to every atom that forms
the earth
and so which way is it going to point to
well it's going to point towards the
center
that's how gravity works that is the
mechanism of gravity
and just in case you have to rub it in
here's the mechanism for
air okay this is air we have all these
uh
atoms that form what we call air and all
these atoms are
also pulled because they're tied
physically tied to every atom that
comprises the earth including the oceans
including the
crust and everything underneath so if
everything's pulled
by every every every atom is pulled by
every other atom that comprises this
system
where do you think all the atoms are
going to point to well all of them are
going to point towards the center of the
earth
that's why water curves and that's why
air curves around our planet
yes the earth is spherical is not a disk
okay and uh yeah people who believe in
this
uh the flat earth
that's their version okay the circle
that's the uh version of the flat
earthers something like that you know
it's a little wafer how thick is thick
that's uh you know how flat is flat
that's a nice question these people
should answer
with that i'll see you on